here in this part of chicago a lot of
folks list this neighborhood as a food
desert
a lot of places that got abandoned
buildings but not a place that do a lot
of healthy food in the neighborhood
i want to take the opportunity to go
around show people how to farm show them
that this type of work is healing
this great big story was made possible
by horizon organic
[Music]
my name is malcolm mevis i am the farm
manager here at urban gross collective
[Music]
the farm we own now is the south chicago
farm and this our main farm here
[Music]
grow all different type of vegetables
spinach spring onions arugula lettuce
mix collard greens different type of
varieties of radishes
after we harvest it we put it on the bus
for fresh move
fresh most market is literally a market
that moves it's a chicago transit
authority bus that got transformed into
a place where people can come on board
instead of going to the destination can
purchase healthy food
our focus for fresh moves geographically
is the south side and the west side of
chicago
these neighborhoods have historically
not had healthy food access this one
give it about one more day it's ready to
go
we harvest and sell probably two tons of
food every week
we're able to bring the freshest highest
quality affordable produce
we have really consistent folks who come
and shop and
people love it they joke when their
favorite thing is not there and you know
come back and expect to see it next week
and
it's a pretty joyful exchange between
everybody and
definitely like keeps us motivated to
know that the work that we're doing
makes such a big difference
i definitely see more folks when i'm
doing the fresh mood programs coming on
a bus learning about vegetables and me
talk to them about how healthy this
piece is for them
coming here seeing the stuff grow that i
put in the ground i feel like when i do
the work i do i accomplish something
it makes me feel like yeah these people
is paying attention they see that this
food is life
[Music]
you